in January of 2016 Donald Trump joked
that he could stand in the middle of
Fifth Avenue and shoot someone and he
wouldn't lose any voters and we all
laughed at the time
and after yesterday's Kangaroo Court
Banana Republic Soviet show trial perp
walk of a former president and current
leader of the political opposition
I'm pretty much there
I'm pretty much there as we all expected
the libs in New York have finally
crossed the Rubicon I know I'm mixing
metaphors I don't care the libs finally
made good on their threats to arrest
Donald Trump and that wasn't even the
craziest part the craziest part of the
34 count indictment
is that they still haven't told us what
they are Prosecuting him for
because the case against Trump is not
actually about any alleged hush money
payment to Stormy Daniels or whatever
if that were the issue which in this
case I don't think would even rise to
the level of a misdemeanor but even if
it did
if that were the issue the New York D.A
would not have been able to bring any
charges because the statute of
limitations ran out years ago
the legal case for arresting Donald
Trump rests entirely on elevating that
possible misdemeanor to a felony
and the only way the prosecution could
possibly make that argument is by tying
the alleged hush money payment to some
other crime
so we were all waiting yesterday to find
out what that other crime was and the
craziest part is that even after the
perp walk even after the arraignment
even after the release of the statements
of facts in the case the prosecution
still has not said what the supposed
crime was
from a legal perspective
the whole thing is just a complete farce
and the Democrats know that which is why
they aren't putting all their anti-trump
eggs in one basket how many more
metaphors can I use the Democrats seem
to be anticipating that the New York
case is likely to fail so they're moving
full steam ahead on investigating Trump
for keeping some documents in his home a
supposed crime that Joe Biden has just
in the last few months been caught
committing 10 times over whatever Trump
did of course without a prosecution and
if that investigation fails to get him
the libs are trying to prosecute Trump
in Georgia for calling the Secretary of
State after the 2020 election and
complaining about apparent fraud every
case they are currently bringing is so
transparently absurd just like every
case they've tried to bring for eight
years from russiagate to Ukraine gate to
Insurrection gate all of which went
precisely nowhere it's all just so
patently absurd
I think they've proven Trump's 2016
prophecy right
because these boys have cried wolf so
many times that's one last metaphor they
have cried wolf so many times
that I think at this point Trump
probably could shoot a guy on Fifth
Avenue in broad daylight and the
reasonable response
would be to assume the Democrats just
pulled yet another optical illusion I'm
Michael Knowles Michael Knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show in just a
moment we will get to Marjorie Taylor
green Republican member of Congress
calling the Democrats the party of petos
she said it many people were thinking it
but she said it we'll get to that in one
second first though on this case it's
not just
Trump defending himself it's not just
the trumpers defending him
even CNN is admitting that this legal
case that D.A Alvin Bragg brought out
is very weak
how strong this case may be or may not
be
um your reaction now that you've had a
chance to go through it
um
is it what you thought it was going to
be and are you unimpressed it is what I
thought it was going to be in terms of
focusing on the payments that were made
the falsification of the records in
really tied to the payment that was made
to Stormy Daniels in terms of a case
that's being brought against a former
president it's a little underwhelming
um there's there's not more to it uh
there's not more violations tax
violations
um there's not an incredible new set of
facts that we didn't know about publicly
it's really the facts of this case as
they have existed for basically almost
seven years
it's a little underwhelming says CNN of
course they have to it's preposterous
they don't even tell you what the charge
is the the crime on which the felony
hinges on which bringing the case at all
hinges they don't tell you what that
crime is because there isn't one
so it's a joke legally it's a joke
but this is not the end let's say that
this gets laughed out of a courtroom
finally the judge comes to his senses
even though it's kind of an anti-trump
judge we'll get to that in a moment too
let's say it gets laughed out of the
courtroom eventually
well they're just going to try them in
DC
they're going to get that
special counsel to go after Trump in DC
for for all of his alleged
misdeeds then they're going to try to
get the the Georgia prosecutors to go
after him there for all of his alleged
misdeeds down there and it's never going
to end
what are they going after him for out of
DC well he had he had classified
documents at his home but he was
President of the United States he had
the ability to declassify any documents
he wanted simply by thinking it so it's
not like he had to go through any formal
process
and Joe Biden had
many documents at many locations from
the time he was vice president when he
didn't have the authority to declassify
documents at a whim
so whatever crime Trump allegedly
committed Biden committed it ten times
over
will they say okay well no the crime
isn't that that Trump took the documents
the crime is that Trump obstructed
Justice because he was trying to stop
them from getting the documents we know
that's not true we know that Trump was
working with the National Archives we
have paperwork to that effect
when the National Archives said okay Mr
President well can you just put another
lock on the door that's what they he
said I'm storing these documents in a
very secure location and they knew where
the location was they saw the documents
and they said okay just put another lock
on the door so that's legally a joke
and then what they're going to get him
in Georgia because he called the
Secretary of State and said there were
Shenanigans in the 2020 election which
we all know
we all know that the Democrats changed
all the election rules right before the
election we all know that when it looked
like Trump was going to win they stopped
counting the votes in the middle of the
night we all know there are Shenanigans
in every election and 2020 was
particularly egregious we've heard the
phone call Trump calls it a perfect
phone call I'm not saying it's the
perfect phone call of all time but
you've heard the phone call
we're gonna we're gonna put a former
president in the political opposition
leader in an orange jumpsuit for that
phone call give me a break
so what's their hope what are they doing
it's just spaghetti at the wall it's
it's the same thing they did with the
Mueller probe it's the same thing they
did with Ukraine gate it's the same
thing they do with everything they're
just trying to to muddy it all up
they're just trying to slow down Trump's
campaign and the only conviction that
they're really hoping for
is a conviction in the court of public
opinion which appears to be working
there's a CNN poll so take it with a
grain of salt that shows that 60 of
Americans support Trump's indictment
94 of Democrats of course
62 percent of independents
and 21 of Republicans
that's all the squishes every single
squish in America as a republican
supports Trump's indictment
so it's over
roughly two-thirds of those adults
surveyed said they support the decision
to indict Trump but the trick of this
poll is
the poll was taken
before we knew what Trump was being
indicted for
the poll was was taken before the
statement of facts came out so 60 of
Americans said they supported Trump's
indictment without knowing what he did
foreign
which is what what Nancy Pelosi
insinuated last week when she said
listen Donald Trump will have the
opportunity in court to prove his
innocence
is that the way our justice system is
supposed to work
you are guilty until proven innocent men
are women babies aren't people
foreigners are Americans and you're
guilty until proven innocent that's
that's the world according to the lips I
think we need to hire some New Elites to
run our country when you want to hire
the best people you got to check out
ZipRecruiter right now go to
ziprecruiter.com Knowles hiring used to
be really hard you would post your job
on multiple sites you would hope the
right people would see it and then you'd
wait for them to apply same goes for
finding a job you upload your resume to
every job posting site and you comb
through never-ending lists of jobs
trying to find the right position for
you ZipRecruiter is the best place to
find the right position or if you're an
employer the right person to join your
team head on over to ziprecruiter.com
Knowles try it for free ziprecruiter's
matching technology excels at finding
the most qualified candidates for a wide
range of roles if you see a candidate
you like you can easily send them a
personal invite so they're more likely
to apply it also gives you a Competitive
Edge against other employers who may
also be interested in that candidate
their user-friendly dashboard makes it
easy to filter review and rate your
candidates all from one place four out
of five employers who post on
ZipRecruiter he had a quality candidate
within the first day see for yourself go
to ziprecruiter.com Knowles to try
ZipRecruiter for free the
ziprecruiter.com
ZipRecruiter the smartest way to hire
so we can laugh at all of these Democrat
plots and schemes and we can say it's
just as ridiculous as Russia gate and
Ukraine gate and the Stormy Daniels
thing which they're resurrecting on no
basis and the phone call and the he
stored some documents like every other
president does and we can all laugh at
that
but what is the cumulative effect even
if if not one single one of these
schemes Works to take down Trump
they always tell us the walls are
closing in this is the end of trump he's
we've got him now
well even if not one of them
is plausible or can stand on its own
what happens when you just throw all
that spaghetti at the wall
what they're hoping for is you can
convince a majority of Americans that
he's guilty without them even knowing
what the crime is and what they're
hoping for is that they can convince the
top dollar Republican donors not to
donate to Trump's presidential campaign
because they are not going to allow him
to mount a serious presidential campaign
if he starts doing too well in the polls
they'll put him in an orange jumpsuit
they'll lock him up
that's what they're trying to do now
speaking of fake news we saw yesterday a
master class in the anatomy of a fake
news story and it was around this Trump
arraignment
As Trump is being arraigned
Trump's son Don Jr
posts a news story to social media
this is a published news story about how
the daughter of the judge in the Trump
case
was an employee of the Biden Harris
campaign
seems relevant
not saying it means the judge has to
recuse himself but it seems relevant to
the case
that was the first part
next part Joyce Aileen
who is some MSNBC talking head lady she
said
Donald Trump Jr has posted a picture of
the judge's daughter on Truth social
picture wait what what are you talking
about and then
AOC tweets out because nothing says
innocent like threatening a judge's
family threatening a judge's family wait
what oh what did Don Jr do let me I
gotta go back now I'm getting confused a
little bit what it is what is it that oh
Don Jr
posted a news article
that was reported in multiple Outlets
to social media
well he he posted a picture of the no he
posted a news article and I guess the
news article had a picture of her but a
lot of news articles have pictures of
this woman when we say judge's daughter
we're not talking about a seven-year-old
kid here we're talking about a
30-something-year-old Democrat operative
who is a well-known Democrat operative
who was highlighted in campaigns and
elections magazine that's the trade
that's the the trade magazine of
political Consultants she was picked in
that magazine as a rising star
and somehow posting a news article on a
major website becomes Trump
is threatening the judge's family
I'm all for keeping the kids out of out
of these political things but what the
daughter is a political professional who
works for Biden areas who has worked for
Biden Harris and for lots of other
Democrat campaigns and that's the fake
news story and now what what the people
are going to walk away from the low
information voters who don't pay close
attention to the news who who believe
that CNN is a real news channel
they're going to walk away and they'll
say oh wow that Trump that mobster he's
threatening judge's daughters
it's the same thing that happened to me
at CPAC a month ago
when I I went to CPAC and I said a
transgenderism the whole Preposterous
ideology has to be eradicated from
public life especially for the good of
the people who have fallen prey to it
and then what's the headline Knowles
calls to eradicate transgender people
and then what does the White House say
this conservative speaker he just came
out he said he wants to eradicate people
and then what happens
a bunch of disingenuous cynical
political hacks and a bunch of sincere
low-information voters who believe what
they hear from the news and the Press
Secretary of the president of the United
States
they conclude
that yours truly Moi whom everybody
loves so called to genocide people and
that's what sticks in people's minds
this is the anatomy of a fake news story
and it is what Trump has dealt with
every single second of his political
career
and that's how sixty percent of
Americans say the guy ought to be
indicted before we even know what he's
accused of doing
now there's a funny Coda to the
arraignment yesterday this was just a
great little happy coincidence
as the libs in New York are persecuting
this man over nothing the ninth Circuit
Court of Appeals just hours after the
arraignment
ordered Stormy Daniels to pay Donald
Trump
almost 122 thousand dollars in attorney
fees
on top of the roughly half million
dollars that she already owes him for
bringing a frivolous suit against Trump
so as we're being told
we have to break
the entire political tradition of the
United States to arrest a former
president current leader of the
opposition
over
not just the hush money payments because
that crime doesn't rise to the right
level but some other unnamed crime that
has something to do with it as that's
all going down in New York totally
unprecedented hurling us into Banana
Republic territory
the ninth Circuit Court of Appeal says
oh by the way Stormy Daniels you owe
Trump money for lying
so what is Trump doing Trump he's a
random New York he flies back to
Mar-A-Lago and he goes on the offense
this is where
are right now
Kamala Harris
and now receives money from the Biden
Harris campaign and a lot of men
we recently had another trial and the
same judge told the fine man who worked
for me for many many years
that if you admit your guilt
you will be in jail for 90 days
but if you don't
if we go through a trial and you're
found guilty you're going away for 10
years and maybe longer
which for a 75 year old man with a great
family
really means life
what the prosecutors and judge did to
that man I will never forget
because it's right out of the old Soviet
Union that's where we are it is it is
right out of the old Soviet Union this
is a ridiculous show trial there's no
way Trump can get a fair trial in New
York obviously it's and so what Trump is
doing here is he's going on the offense
and that's what he has to do
what Trump has to do here
is put this prosecutor and put this
judge in his political crosshairs
and what the libs are going to say is
you're calling for violence
you're you're threatening these you know
we're not calling for the destruction of
their persons we're calling for the
destruction of their reputation and
Trump has to do it one because they
deserve it two
because
it's the only way that he's going to
keep that Mojo up
it sounds like violence no it's not by
the way Donald Trump didn't murder Jeb
Bush in 2016. Donald Trump didn't murder
Marco Rubio in 2016. Donald Trump didn't
murder every other candidate on that
stage but he he destroyed their
political reputations
and Trump has to do that again
not not just to fend off these legal
challenges not just defend off the
Democrats
defend off the other Republicans because
the other Republicans
are going to take this opportunity to
say Trump is weak
they've got him now the walls are
closing in this is our our opportunity
to gain some Advantage here so even to
defend his position within the
Republican Party Trump needs to remind
people
what it's like to get on the wrong side
of Donald Trump and he's doing that he's
getting his mojo back that's what we
want to see we don't want to see nice
polite Donald Trump from the campaign
announcement at Mar-A-Lago which was a
little bit
of an of of an underwhelming experience
we want to see Donald Trump on the
ground in East Palestine Ohio
bragging about how he bullied Joe Biden
to finally pay some attention to that
town we want to see Donald Trump going
there getting into these people's faces
getting into their political background
and and rightly destroying their
political standings what they are doing
is
is the destruction of our country of our
system of Law and Order what they are
doing is thrusting us
further into Banana Republic Soviet show
trial realm than I ever thought we would
get in my lifetime
this whole idea actually gave me a
little bit of a tangential shock
yesterday which is that as this was
happening I said wow I can't believe
this is really happening in America and
I I had just signed up for some of the
AI programs because I'm just curious to
see how good the AI programs are so I
went to one of the AI programs and I
typed in Donald Trump as the defendant
in a courtroom full of kangaroos so
something to that effect I typed in one
or two prompts it was not very
complicated
and the AI spit out
an amazing courtroom image you know the
in that style of drawing that you see
from courtroom images of Donald Trump
sitting as a defendant with a kangaroo
with a little smirk on his face sitting
there as a juror
it's it's probably the most widely
shared political cartoon of yesterday
and I was able to spit it out I didn't
spit it out at all I just typed it in it
took like 30 seconds
so wow that was really really fast and
then
I came up with another even more
evocative and actually somewhat
disturbing political cartoon
and it told me a lot not just about the
the Trump trial told me not even just
this political moment it told me a lot
about what AI is about to mean for our
whole society which we'll get to in one
second firstly you got to restore a
little balance to your life that's why
you got to check out balance of nature
right now go to balanceofnature.com
promo code Knowles living a healthy
lifestyle is not always easy especially
when you like me are always on the go
you need simple manageable routines to
make sure you're getting the proper
nutrition every day that is why I'm a
huge fan of balance of nature balance of
nature fruits and veggies are a great
way to make sure you're getting
essential nutritional ingredients every
single day their capsules are packed
with 100 whole food that you can take at
any time balance of nature uses a cold
vacuum process that preserves the
natural phytonutrients in 16 whole
fruits and 15 whole vegetables and
encapsulates them for easy consumption
balance of nature sent a bunch of their
products down to the studio for our team
to try and these jackals here at the
Dale they wire these absolute hyena
animals just pounced on them so that I
sometimes am not even able to get my own
hands on very very frustrating you can
get your own at balanceofnature.com use
promo code Knowles kwles for 35 off your
first order as a preferred customer
that's balanceofnature.com promo code
nulls for 35 off your first order
you know there's a line of scripture
that says faith is the substance of
things hoped for in the evidence of
things that not seen now you might ask
why do you need Faith why doesn't God
just lay it all out for us on the table
well novelist Greg hurtwitz has an
interesting theory about that and he
shares it with the Roundtable group of
Scholars in Jordan Peterson's episode 13
of Exodus I think if you could see God
clearly you wouldn't need Faith right so
it's a precursor in a lot of ways to
Freedom if you could see God it would be
so undeniable like first you die but
then additionally everything that he
would say would have to be absolute and
that's a kind of authoritarianism and so
it's like the faith of the belief is
what allows the freedom to keep falling
and drinking wine and picnicking and
making golden calves and every time he's
out of sight there's a fall and then
there's a movement back again so you're
suggesting if there wasn't a veil there
there'd be everything would be so
understandable to us that we could just
follow it like automatons that right
then you're back to the Pharaoh in a way
in addition to Greg Jordan is joined by
a group of esteemed Scholars theologians
and artists including our own Mr Ben
Shapiro in this episode for an in-depth
discussion on one of the seminal books
of the Bible new episodes come online
every week exclusively for daily wire
Plus members join now at dailywire.com
subscribe to watch at Exodus
so I made this little political cartoon
with a kangaroo in the court okay then I
said
one of my other conclusions here is that
in New York you could indict a ham
sandwich so I said okay give me a give
me a ham sandwich that looks like Trump
whatever I wrote it wasn't all that much
more complicated than that and it spits
out
and if you're listening to this right
now you've got just go online look it up
later it's so shocking it's this
surreal photo realistic image of a
sandwich with a trump face in the ham
with his little pout and his blonde
eyebrows and the eyebrows and the hair
are made of cheese whiz and it's really
a brilliant piece of art
that this computer made
in like a minute
now this is going to put a lot of
artists out of work or it's going to
radically change the nature of artists
work it's going to change the nature of
political cartoons because the first two
political cartoons of this
Trump arraignment which is an historic
event we're just spit out by a computer
because I was goofing around within a
matter of minutes
but but this poses a real risk for
society broadly
is the trend we have seen in society
over certainly the last 30 years but
really at a much longer time scale than
that
is a trend toward atomization
a trend away from communal activities
toward individual activities
so we don't have bowling leagues really
anymore we don't have the Lions Club
anymore I mean these things exist but
people just don't participate in them as
they used to people don't really go to
their churches anymore people are not as
involved in their communities anymore
people don't have a ton of kids anymore
and so they're they're just people don't
sit on their front porches anymore
they're more likely to sit on their back
decks this was a trend observed in the
70s in a famous architectural book so
all all of the movement of society is
toward this individualism
with the Advent of computers people
spend a lot more time in their own
little Affinity groups online they don't
spend time with their real Community
they spend time with their virtual
community
then
with the Advent of all sorts of new
ideologies which percolate all around
the internet people begin to live
according to different understandings of
reality
most clearly you see this with the
transgender idea in our country right
now we can't even agree on how to know
things what a human being is what are
men what are women we don't agree on
that anymore
we are we might occupy the same
geographical area but we are living in
different realities now one of the last
shared things we had was art
and increasingly people don't watch the
same TV shows now we have streaming on
demand
people don't watch the same movies
people just watch movies streaming on
demand and they can be tiny little
movies that that don't have the same box
office numbers that people used to have
even art we now have art on demand
then it really got me thinking you know
you know
what this this AI stuff is in its early
stages but you know once they get it
anywhere near a commercially viable
place
you know it's going to all be porn right
it's like the whole internet it's just
it's all going to be born and the
scariest part about it is
you can then just make your own porn
and and I was talking with sweet little
Elise about this last night that once
they perfect this AI so that now you can
create these whatever images you want or
even video which they're already working
on previously AI was not that convincing
it's kind of blurry the hands are kind
of a little messed up but within about
six months now it's really really good
the hands are are basically totally
right
once they perfect
the AI technology so that it spreads all
over porn and they perfect sex robots
the human race is going to go extinct
because people are just they're just
going to create
their own fantasies they're just going
to increasingly live in their own
fantasies
what's crazy about this I I promise you
this will happen people will just be
because people are very naughty and we
don't have a lot of restrictions on
society people are going to create porn
of private citizens that they know The
Girl Next Door the
girl and I don't know the girl in math
class or something
it's it's going to be a huge
legal challenge but how do you how do
you put Pandora's Pandora's stuff back
in her box I don't know how you can do
that so the effect I don't mean to just
focus on the weird sex stuff which seems
to dominate our politics these days but
but it's evocative because sex is so
important to the to The Human Condition
and it's such a motivator of our of our
activities but it's true of everything
we're just gonna live
in our own little safe spaces that are
completely concocted within our own
realities
this is what's so troubling to
conservatives about the transgender
ideology
is there's there's no communicating with
someone who says yeah you can never know
what I really believe what I really see
there's no objective truth that we can
communicate about
I just am whatever I say I am and you
have to deal with that so well then that
means that there's nothing objective and
intelligible about the universe it means
that we can't use our faculty as a
reason since we can't govern ourselves
it's just the it's just the total
atomization of society
you see I guess the reason the the porn
aspect of it all stuck out to me is
because porn is such a perversion of the
basic political institution basic
political institution is the marriage
where you give yourself holy to the
other person and your love is so real
with your spouse that it actually
creates a third person
and porn is just the complete inversion
of that
and you and you see that that phenomenon
take place throughout every other level
of
Society
speaking of sexual dysfunction I have a
I have a story to get to on that front
but I'm sure we'll be banned from
YouTube for doing it so Sal have to I'll
have to choose my words very very
carefully there's a study
out of Northwestern
which finds what am I allowed to say
guys and why I do I guess you got to go
to dailywire.com And subscribe and
become a member so you can hear my words
that won't be bleeped out this is a
scientific study I'm just reading from a
scientific study okay I got it right
here
it says
pre-existing mental health issues were
common
and youths with these issues were more
likely than those without them to have
socially and medically
[Music]
I'm just reading verbatim from this
scientific study you can't censor me for
that can you can you maybe that's the
kind of society we're living we're
living in a society where the ruling
class where the regime arrests the
leader of the opposition the former
president so maybe we are living in that
Society very important study though
because what we're told is
if you don't
indulge the fantasies of
sexually confused people you're
effectively killing them these are
life-saving treatments when we chop off
the healthy genitals of confused young
people we're that's saving their lives
because their mental health will
deteriorate and they'll commit suicide
if we don't all pretend that they're the
opposite sex and we don't all live in
lies
what this study says is no actually the
opposite is true what this study says is
what we all knew intuitively which is
that when you encourage confused and
isolated people
and people who have already a somewhat
tenuous grasp on reality when you
encourage them to go further into their
own fantasies further into their own AI
create your own reality kind of
Daydreams their mental health doesn't
improve it deteriorates
because
mental health which is just the new
euphemism that we use for sanity
reasonableness
it hinges on our ability to perceive and
understand the objective World outside
of us of course you don't need a
scientific study to tell you that but we
now have one and I promise you the libs
are going to try to cover it up
now
we have
a wonderful segment coming up tomorrow
that would be my favorite segment of the
week the voicemail back when I get to
hear from you if you
do not know how to submit a voicemail by
question you go to dailywire.com
click on watch you scroll down to the
Michael Knowles show there she is right
there
click the Michael Knowles show then you
click the mailbag and then it opens up a
little email you can either write in
your question or
you can record your question on your
phone or on your computer keep it under
a minute please so I can play it on the
show
and then attach that file send it in
and I will get to hear your mellifluous
dulcet tones
that will be I'm sorry that's on Friday
that's not tomorrow it's in this whole
week man we're arresting presidents over
here I'm losing track of the days you
know my favorite comment yesterday
whatever day that was is from oze who
says some people won't eat meat with
added hormones but will then turn around
and give actual hormones to their kids I
know this is
this is the same phenomenon of liberals
who are vegan who not only won't eat
meat they won't eat fish
they won't even eat eggs and cheese and
milk
so so worried are they for the
well-being of the little chicken
but they'll murder a baby
they won't eat an anchovy because that
would be evil and that would be taking
life but they'll murder a baby in the
womb it doesn't I don't mean to laugh
it's just either you laugh or cry it's
so so dark and it's so completely
incoherent it's a great that's a great
Point great way to color that with the
new gender ideology speaking of that
ideology
Taylor green
uh was just on 60 Minutes with Leslie
Stahl and Leslie Stahl thought she had a
real gotcha from Marge retailer green
you know Marjorie has said things that
are
provocative no doubt but she's pretty
conservative she's pretty clear in what
she thinks and so Leslie Stahl thought
she really had her and she was going to
get Marjorie green to walk back a
terrible hyperbolic line that she said
here's marjorie's response
says that are over the top like the
Democrats are a party of pedophiles
I would definitely say so they support
grooming children
I just Marjorie doesn't miss a Beat
Marjorie you you've said here it says on
this chord that the Democrats are a
party of pedophiles just doesn't she
doesn't even believe she goes I would
definitely say that yeah oh I said that
yeah I get I would say that because it's
obviously true
keep going why would you say that
Democrats Democrats support even Joe
Biden the president himself supports
children being sexualized and having
transgender surgeries sexualizing
children is what pedophiles do to
children
okay
you
huh
I don't have any response to that so
I'll just I'll just sort of roll my eyes
hi wow
so what's Marjorie saying
I agree that Marjorie Taylor green is
being about
four percent hyperbolic
I agree politicians speak in hyperbole
they use really blunt statements to get
their message across and sometimes
they're hyperbolic and so sure I'll
agree with the Democrats Marjorie Taylor
green is being hyperbolic here by about
three and a half percent
we're not saying every Democrat
wants to do weird sex stuff with kids
buy it
it is undeniable that the Democrats have
taken a bizarre
interest
a bizarre sexual interest in children
and they're obsessed with it and they
never shut up about it
conservatives didn't start this fight
we didn't bring up this issue everything
was going just fine
it was the Democrats who said we need to
go into the elementary schools and talk
about weird sex stuff with your kids
they said oh please don't do that why
are you so obsessed with talking about
sex and kids No you're the one who's
obsessed with you you're the one who
wanted to go into the kindergarten and
talk about weird sex stuff
it was the Democrats who said we want to
go into the I don't know why they all
have the same voice they're all got the
same kind of
demonic ideas I guess we we want to go
into the public library and walk in in
stilettos and mini skirts as big hulking
dudes and then twerk for your little
toddlers and that's a civil right It's a
Blessing of Liberty it's called drag
queen story hour and then conservative
said
um don't please
how about we don't do that that seems
weird why are you so obsessed no you're
obviously the ones
you're obviously the one who's obsessed
Democrats are the ones who are saying
that teachers and guidance counselors
and and political activists need to be
able to convince your son that he's a
girl
and your daughter that she's a boy and
then start calling them by the names
that are appropriate to the opposite sex
and the pronouns for the opposite sex
and in some cases even put them on
puberty blockers or cross-sex hormones
start transitioning them without
parents
knowledge or consent
it's the Democrats doing that Democrat
and it's not just some Fringe people
it's
the assistant Secretary of Health for
the Biden Administration it's Joe Biden
himself
and the whole executive branch and the
leading Democrats in the country they're
all pushing this
they have a weird sexual interest in
children
whether that means they're lusting after
children or whether that means they just
have a really messed up view of sex and
children Marjorie green says it's a pedo
party
it's not that much of an exaggeration
and please spare me the the sermons
about
hyperbolic political rhetoric okay these
are the Democrats who say that anyone
who disagrees with them anybody slightly
to the right of Barack Obama is a Nazi
is Hitler is racist is a white
supremacist they say that about anybody
they'll say it about they'll call black
people white supremacists if they in any
way diverge from the orthodoxies of the
Democrat Party so please spare me the
lectures about hyperbole Marjorie Taylor
green is being slightly hyperbolic but
but it's it's really weird you know I
wrote about this in my book speechless
controlling words controlling Minds
which is available for order right now
number one National bestseller thank you
very much
back in 1969
Bernie Sanders was trying to get himself
into politics he was mostly failing
obviously it finally worked out but in
in 1969
Bernie Sanders wrote in the Vermont
Freeman
a weird essay about
how we should sexualize children he
wrote These are his exact words quote in
Vermont at a State Beach a mother is
reprimanded by Authority for allowing
her six-month-old daughter to go about
without her diapers on now if children
go around naked they are liable to see
each other's sexual organs and maybe
even touch them terrible thing if we
bring children up like this it will
probably ruin the whole pornography
business not to mention the large
segment of the general economy which
makes its money by playing on people's
sexual frustrations the revolution is
coming and it is a very beautiful
Revolution
it is beautiful because in its deepest
sense it is quiet gentle and all
pervasive it knows so it's kind of
strange prose I give you that but it's
it's an ironic piece
he's saying oh you know on a beach uh
a young girl is reprimanded for not
having her clothes on oh because heaven
for Finn she goes around without her
clothes and then kids might see each
other's sexual organs and maybe they'll
even touch them oh that would be
terrible because that would ruin the
pornography business and that would ruin
their sexual frustrations later on so
what he's arguing is kids should be
allowed to
see and play with each other's sexual
organs and and this idea
of the importance of sexualizing
children derives from an intellectual
who was very prominent on the left
Wilhelm Reich who Wilhelm Reich had this
thought
that all the problems of the world
political dysfunction War Death cancer
everything derived from a lack of
orgasms I'm not joking I know it's that
sounds like a punch line that's really
what he believed he thought that the
essence of life the the energy that that
animated life was something called the
orgone he created a device called the
orgone accumulator which was a wooden
box that weirdo leftists would sit in I
don't know what they did in the box and
the idea was to accumulate organs and
and
well to put it bluntly the more orgasms
one had the healthier one would be
and there was a push
at younger and younger ages to
sexualized Children this back in the age
of Aquarius when when these people were
just weirdo hippies now those weirdo
hippies are U.S senators
now those weirdo hippies are running the
country
it's been building for a very very long
time
and so now we see this push not only to
reduce the age of consent now we see
this push there's a pervert uh state
senator in California Scott weiner I
think his name is
all nature is but art unknown today and
this guy Senator weiner he he campaigned
to pass this bill that would reduce
punishments for pederasts for grown men
who engaged in sexual asks so who
molested young boys
that that was that was something that he
campaigned on and he he won he got it he
got it through
I believe I'm correct in saying that
Senator weiner also campaigned on
decriminalizing the transmission the The
Knowing willful transmission of HIV to a
sexual partner really really weird stuff
but for our conversation here especially
important to note that he pushed to
normalize sex with minors
he pushed to reduce punishments
specifically for gay sex with minors
there's a movement for that and now you
know the libs nationally are pushing not
only to do weird sex stuff with kids all
over the age of consent or reduce the
penalties for having sex with minors
they're pushing now to allow miners to
permanently mutilate their sexual organs
not at 15 or 16 or 14 all the way down
to like eight okay
it's happening right now and so Marjorie
green goes on TV and says
it's a pedo party I don't know is that
so hyperbolic I don't think so
speaking of
speaking of female political leaders
Finland
the newest NATO country of every country
on Earth is going to be in NATO pretty
soon just before World War Three starts
Finland just ousted its left-wing prime
minister
Santa Marin
in a narrow three-way Race Santa Maran
you might recall as being the hottest
world leader that's what she was known
for okay there were a lot of news
articles written about it she's just a
young physically attractive woman and
she would go out and party and do all
sorts of weird crazy things and there
were videos of this she shut her phone
off she wouldn't wouldn't answer
government calls she'd be out just
dancing at the club and this is really
bizarre especially because she is pretty
young and pretty good looking and now
she's been ousted from Power which which
is a little Ray of Hope
in an otherwise depressing news cycle
because the Ray of Hope here is not just
that the right can take countries back
maybe we can maybe we can the Hope here
is
people still value competence
just a little bit of a different thing
than the ideological battle
competence can you do the basic
rudimentary tasks that are required of
politicians can you keep the economy
from imploding can you keep the banking
system from imploding can you keep
inflation from hitting 40-year highs can
you keep Energy prices down can you stop
World War III from potentially opening
up in Europe can you stop oh yeah I'm
listing a lot of things here that
unfortunately our current
commander-in-chief has not been able to
do
which is why of course they're going
after Trump so hard
if they really believe Joe Biden won by
the most votes ever cast in any election
ever in the history of the world the
99.7 percent of more a greater
percentage of Americans voted for Biden
than Iraqis who voted for Saddam Hussein
that's how popular he is it probably it
is if they really believe that they
wouldn't have to try to throw Trump in
jail three different times on bogus
charges and it's not just Trump by the
way
uh Democrats have just dumped 500 pages
of Oppo research on the number two
Republican candidate in the race Ron
DeSantis this is American Bridge 21st
century it's one of the largest tracking
and research groups in Progressive
politics so it's it's not some Fringe
group it's a it's a big one they just
released a new website after spending
the last year Gathering Oppo on DeSantis
they're branding him as a Maga extremist
this is the same group that launched the
Trump research book in 2020 which is a
similarly comprehensive account of all
of Donald Trump's alleged crimes
all of which is to say a lot of people
are trying to prognosticate and read
crystal balls and tea leaves to say the
Democrats were arresting Trump because
they secretly want him to be the nominee
it's 5D chess no they they are most
terrified of it being the nominee no
they actually want DeSantis actually
they want that forget about that for a
second
just focus on the basic stuff
they know that Biden is very very weak
they know that this ideology is
unpopular they know that parents don't
actually want to chop their kids
genitals off
they know that World War III is
unpopular they know that the absolute
economic destruction of just the last
two years is very unpopular
and they know that people can tell that
this guy is not able to do the job so
they fear not just Trump I think they
fear any Republican candidate who could
get the nomination
you think they're going hard after Trump
now it's because he's the number one
candidate if DeSantis somehow becomes
the number one candidate
they're going to go after him just as
hard they're going to try to put him in
an orange jumpsuit too
we've got
a lot coming up
we have got a woke Tick Tock because
this is woke Wednesday so make sure you
stay tuned for that over at the member
block at the Nostradamus member room
segmentum
is it the membrane segmentum I don't
know I have to brush up on my Latin
dailyword.com Knowles become a member
use code Knowles at checkout for two
months free on all annual plans
see you over at the member block
[Music]